Hannah it's lovely to see you at NCM
Comic Con today what kind of Dave been
having at you know what I love these
they're just everyone expressing
themselves how they want to express
themselves it's just a crazy crazy day
but also very nice to meet the fans
because coming from theater you know the
thing I love about theater is the
immediacy of it and you don't get that
and so much with television so it's nice
to come here and have people come and
say I'm really scared of you I think
good you see I'm doing the doing a good
job now of course you are very scary
character on Game of Thrones aren't you
septa unella I mean how did you get into
playing that character and how much fun
is it I think the biggest thing for me
is stripping back because she is so well
she's so
plain it kind of takes you to a certain
place a simple subdued dark minimalistic
place anyway so once all that gear goes
on I feel very different you know as a
woman in modern society so much of our
lives are dictated by our appearance
whether we like it or not and to have
all that removed you know as an actress
that's usually played glamorous
characters it's kind of a shock at first
but I loved it because it lent so much
to me and I love the fact that she is
like I say so economical with her facial
expressions with what she says you know
it and it's a pleasure to play her and
lock into a very different rhythm and
very different thought pattern and of
course talking about you know stripping
everything back you had that incredible
scene shame shame walking Lena Headey
scary to Cersei through the streets in
the walk of atonement what was it like
filming that well the first scene when
we're at the top of the stairs was my
first scene ever on Thrones and I had my
own ten week old baby ten week old baby
in the wings and so I was kind of
thinking oh I feel like I should be with
you but all the while thinking this is
just an extraordinary epic wheel to
become a tiny spoken and it was a real
pleasure and has continued to be quite
an overwhelming thrill I can imagine you
get rather a few people coming up and
saying that words you do you I do but I
love it because it means that I've done
my job properly and I don't think even
David and Dad
knew that this character would be so
loved and now so loved / hated from from
basically barking two words at Cersei
and what was it like playing part of
that faith militant brilliant because
there is a quiet power to them I mean a
massive power to them and as a whole
myself Jonathan Pryce and the and the
faith militant and Eugene as well it's a
collective of oddballs who unbeknownst
to the the royalty have really come in
and started running the show and have
kind of slapped around the face and
shocked them what's your take on the
high Sparrow
well une Ella is just in awe of him and
I think she's worked very hard to become
his right hand henchwoman I like that
description of her although he did say
to Marjorie I think it was this season
that your devotions taking a little bit
too far because you did almost hit
Marjorie didn't you know you can't prove
it
I think she's become a little overly
devout because she just wants to please
him and I think for me personally I
purposely play a deeper layer of wanting
approval from him because she she
doesn't look up to many people in life
but he is her her master I mean what do
you think
another would think if she heard him say
that you've taken your devotion too far
I think she'd go into her cell and
flagellate with her order of the seven
Bible now of course we we think we've
got a scene coming up with you as well
with Marjorie
we've had it teased was episode six
season six yes it looks a little bit
different than the walk of shame that
you did with Cersei because there's no
head shaved yet in the picture anyway
not naked and all of this you tease a
little bit for us what we might see from
septa unella for the rest of the season
you might see some things
and that's it the nasty thing yeah well
no but she doesn't think any of her
behavior is last he she is clarifying
and cleansing and just bringing people
back to who they were when they came
into this world instead of the you know
self-absorbed self-obsessed dollies that
they've become I talk about self absorbs
the self assess last season when you had
her in the tower
Cersei in the cell so as he said to you
that her face would be the last face
that you ever saw before you die what do
you think of that what do you think you
think that's going to come true with
septa unella ah I don't think that septa
unella is particularly bothered because
when it's her time to go it's her time
to go and the gods will allow her to
atone for her behavior which she she she
respects what she's done in her life or
at least the latter part of her life as
a scepter and she will atone accordingly
there's so many great deaths on the show
how would you like to go out how do I
like to go out um slowly
now that sounds ominous and of course
you've got so many great actors on the
show as well you can have anyone come on
Game of Thrones who would you love to
see to come on to the show well I have
to say I think I think the the way
they've picked the people to play these
roles for me there wouldn't be anybody
that I'd like to see this I mean the way
they have cast these roles is just
phenomenal if I could have a scene with
anyone I'd like to have a scene with
Peter Dinklage because I just think he's
got the most phenomenal presence I don't
know in what world maybe we'd meet us
you know wronged brother trying to
defend his sister I don't know whether I
think septa unella might have a little
bit of a cool moment meeting him
thanks thing that you're talking to us
Hannah in a pleasure you're welcome
you